new york magazine's cover features a
trans man who carved a penis out of the
flesh of her leg and joe biden lays out
his new plan for fighting kovid so much
sciencing i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the benchmark show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a rights to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first it is the season of
giving but you've already given way too
much to your internet service provider
like all of your data don't do it again
next year instead why not get expressvpn
i'm not just talking about the enormous
internet bill that you pay every month
that goes to your internet service
provider i'm talking about like all your
private information is viewable by your
isp every time you go online without
express vpn you're leaving that data
unprotected and that means that even
when you're visiting sites in incognito
mode they can still grab that data on
top of what we're charging you these
isps are legally allowed to sell all
your browsing activity to third-party
advertisers at a massive profit that's
why i'm done giving to my isp i always
go online with expressvpn the app
encrypts and reboots 100 of my network
data through their secure servers so my
provider can't see a thing it couldn't
be easier to use too simply fire up
expressvpn on any of your devices phone
laptop whatever tap one button to
connect and that's it unlike your isp
expressvpn is committed to your privacy
the privacy policy has been audited by
third parties so you can rest assured
knowing that your data is not being
logged by anyone so protect yourself
take your privacy back visit
expressvpn.com get three extra months of
expressvpn for free that's
e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
expressvpn.com
ben to learn more alrighty so yesterday
there's an article rocketing around the
internet it was from a new york magazine
the cover of new york magazine featured
a quote unquote trans man meaning a
biological woman who believes that she
is a man
whose new name is gabrielle mack okay
gabrielle or gabriel mack the original
name of this human was in fact mack
mcclellan but then this woman decided
that she is in fact some sort of trans
man and therefore had to appear on the
cover
of new york magazine
in her underwear i say her because i
only use biological pronouns on this
show
in her underwear after having a breast
removal surgery and after having had a
surgery to essentially carve a fake
penis out of her leg and then attach it
to herself
this is what our society has become in
one photo this is what our society has
become when radical subjectivism rules
the roost in reality is forced to bow
before the altar of radical subjectivism
what you end up with is effectively
bodily mutilation there's no way to look
at this photo and not see a form of
bodily mutilation this is literally a
person who's had flesh from her leg
removed in order to carve out a fake
genitalia
and then
say that she has now become a man by the
way this person also says that she has
retained her original female
genitals in terms of her vagina so she
still has a biological vagina and now
has added on a
fake penis through a phalloplasty and i
say fake penis because this is not a
naturally grown thing shall we say it is
it is carved out of human flesh okay now
i don't mean to be
extremely graphic but that's the entire
part of the article the entire point of
the article from new york magazine is to
be as extremely graphic as possible
which is why the photo is on the cover
of new york magazine that's why you have
extremely graphic photos of what the leg
looks like after the removal of the
flesh
and you are supposed to just mirror the
perspective of the article you're
supposed to mirror the idea that this
person used to be a woman and is now a
man
so over the weekend i was rereading 1984
and the truth is that 1984 while it is a
a morality play
about the stalinesque soviet regime
in reality it's a little bit deeper than
that what it really is is about how you
control minds it's about thought crime
and double think and mind control it's
how people's minds are captured and then
used against them and this is what we
are in the midst of culturally in the
united states you are not allowed the
few centimeters in your brain that allow
you a level of thought freedom
that would be to commit a thought crime
if you right now are thinking that this
person obviously suffers from a mental
disorder and i will bring you more
information about this person in just a
moment that this person obviously
suffers from a mental disorder and that
and that brutal surgeries are very
unlikely
to represent a solution to that mental
disorder
if you think that then this means that
you are a vicious terrible person
what's more if you go
even further and you say this person
remains a biological woman
with a diagnosable mental disorder
if you say that then this means that
you're a bigot
now to most people this just sounds like
common sense because
as a rule if you go on the cover of a
magazine
wearing nothing but your underwear
to show the scars from your top surgery
and from
your addition of a of a penis through
phalloplasty by carving flesh from your
leg
this is not a great sign of a mentally
well-ordered person
it just isn't
okay but if you say that then this means
that you are somehow
gender
you are transphobic you are
heteronormative you're cishet right all
of this nonsense
so orwell writes in 1984 and this is
really the essence of 1984 it says
doublethink lies at the very heart of
the regime since the essential act of
the party is to use conscious deception
while retaining the firmness of purpose
that goes with complete honesty to tell
deliberate lies while genuinely
believing in them to forget any fact
that has become inconvenient and then
when it becomes necessary again to draw
it back from oblivion for just so long
as it is needed to deny the existence of
objective reality and all the while to
take account of the reality which ones
and eyes all this is indispensably
necessary
this is correct
this is the the culture that we have now
been creating for ourselves
or while writing about this in the
context of soviet mind control
essentially he says
in the end the party would announce that
two in two made five and you would have
to believe it it was inevitable that
they should make that claim sooner or
later the logic of their position
demanded it not merely the validity of
experience but the very existence of
external reality was tacitly denied by
their philosophy the heresy of heresies
was common sense and what was terrifying
was not that they would kill you for
thinking otherwise but that they might
be right for after all how do we know
that two and two make four or that the
force of gravity works or that the past
is unchangeable if both the past and the
external world exist only in the mind
and if the mind itself is controllable
what then
in order to reach utopia you wonder why
this is part of a left-wing agenda
because really this what does this have
to do with redistribution of income per
se what does this have to do with the
structures of the economy what does this
have to do even with fairness and equity
what does it have to do with any of this
stuff what do bizarre claims about the
nature of gender that are completely
anti-biological and anti-common sense
what does that have to do with any of
this and the answer is it all lies in
the root belief that man is entirely
malleable and that reality exists
entirely in the mind so if we just shift
how we think about reality a man can be
a woman a woman can be a man
all human beings can be remolded and
shaped into utopian forms of themselves
widgets that we can play with from the
top down to create a better society
that is how this particularly bizarre
and radical perspective on gender fits
into the broader left-wing rubric
because once you have subjected yourself
to relentless
subjectivism once you have decided that
radical subjectivism is the truth about
life that reality does not exist out
here there's no such thing as reality
there are no such things as rules rules
of biology do not exist rules of physics
do not exist
rules of history do not nothing exists
the only thing that exists is in your
mind
and that's the only thing that matters
because it grants you a sense of
authenticity once you believe that you
can accomplish anything in this view
that is why this is important
not because this particular person this
particular person doing what this person
wishes to do with their life i disagree
with the decisions i don't think this is
going to alleviate anything i think the
surgeons who perform these sorts of
surgeries are committing a grave sin
against humanity frankly but
adults are adults in a free country
okay that said
the the baseline notion that the rest of
society has to accept as truth something
that is obviously a lie is
extraordinarily dangerous and it ties
into a broader belief system that says
that lies can become the truth so long
as those lies are convenient and
necessary for the pursuit of utopia
in a second i'm gonna get to the story
of this person because i've sort of
alluded to it but the story really does
tell the entire tale we'll get to that
in just one moment
first do you know that garages are the
most frequently accessed entry to the
home the garage is where people most
important to you come and go it houses a
lot of your most prized possessions cars
your tools maybe your old photos it's
common sense to know what's going on in
your garage this is why you need the myq
smart camera by chamberlin it's the only
smart camera optimized for the garage
brought to you by the leaders in garage
door opener technology with features
like live video streaming recorded
events motion detection and two-way
communication right from your phone you
can make sure your garage is secure 24
7. pair it with the myq smart garage
control you'll never have to worry if
you left the garage door open you can
check it see it and close it all the way
from the my q app from anywhere
this is pretty great i mean you forget
that your your garage got left open you
can now close it from your phone
somebody needs to get into the house but
you actually locked your front door well
you can use your phone to let them into
the house all the myq devices work
seamlessly within garage delivery live
video streaming capabilities let you
watch in garage deliveries and packages
and groceries it's easy to install you
can quickly connect it to your phone via
bluetooth what are you waiting for give
the gift of a myq smart garage camera to
your favorite tech lovers this holiday
season if you act right now you can save
46 for a limited time by entering ben at
checkout on myq dot com slash ben that
was ben at checkout on myq dot com ben
to save 46 keep an eye on what's
happening in and around your home's
busiest entryway with the myq smart
garage camera it's the only smart camera
optimized for the garage okay so
before we get to the story the details
of the story i just want to point out
that the typical left-wing response
to anybody even commenting on this is
why do you care
i care because you put this on the cover
of a major national magazine that's why
i care because you made this a national
story a person making what i believe to
be a bad decision for themselves is not
a national news story you made it a
national news story and the reason you
did so is specifically so that when we
comment on it when we notice that you
are fighting against common sense and
frankly common decency
when we notice that you are lying to
people about the malleability of human
sex
when we notice that you call us bigots
and you say why are you even noticing
why why do you notice why do you notice
we're noticing because you have made
this the front line of the culture war
and you want to dictate this to my
children you want to tell my kids that
your view of gender and sex is the real
view of gender and sex and you want to
call anybody who disagrees a bigot
in other words this is bait
but if you don't take debate then they
win because if you don't take debates
then the assumption is that what they
are saying has some relation to reality
or decency and it has no relation to
either
and so honestly i feel terrible for this
human being the reason i feel terrible
for this human being is this person
obviously has serious problems
here is a story from july 5th 2011
journalists stages her own rape to cure
trauma of witnessing sex attack on women
in haiti
for journalist mack mcclelland you'll
notice that
gabriel mack and mack mcclelland are the
same human for journalist mac mcclellan
it gripped her body and her mind in such
a severe way she had to simulate a
violent rape to get over it
the mother jones civil rights reporter
was on a job in haiti in the aftermath
of the 2010 earthquake when she met a
woman she called sybil who had been
raped at gunpoint and brutally mutilated
by a gang of men
after ms mcclellan 31 accompanied her to
the hospital where the surgeon who
performed reconstructive surgery on her
told her she was a and deserved
what she got they were on their way back
in a taxi when civil saw one of the men
who raped her mrs mcclellan recalls she
went into a full paroxysm wailing and
flailing in terror screaming with her
eyes rolling in abject terror it was at
that point that something snapped in
miss mcclellan too despite the fact that
she had seen the impact of sexual
violence all around the globe having
reported from the congo in burma this
incident was more than she could take
according to abc she became
progressively enveloped in the classic
symptoms of post-traumatic stress
avoidance of feelings flashbacks
recurrent thoughts that triggered crying
spells she couldn't get out of bed in
the morning and had nightmares and
daymares about rape
the 31 year old went to see a therapist
in her home of san francisco and despite
getting treatment for ptsd she told her
therapist all she wanted to do was have
incredibly violent sex
her therapist suggested it was a good
idea and told her to find someone who
she trusted enough to do it
miss mcclellan believed it was this
staged violent rape with a close friend
that cured her
she even wrote an article about it for
the online magazine good
in it she explains how her sexual
partner mercilessly pinned her beat her
about the head and brutally violated her
she wrote about the rape i did not enjoy
it in a way a person getting screwed
normally would but as it became clear
that i could endure it i started to take
deeper breaths and my mind stayed there
stayed present even when it became
painful even when he smothered me with a
pillow not to asphyxiate me but so that
he didn't break my jaw when he drew his
elbow back and slammed his fist into my
face two three four times my body felt
devastated but relieved i lost but
survived after he climbed off me he
gathered me up in his arms i broke into
a thousand pieces on his chest sobbing
so hard my rips felt like my ribs felt
like they were coming loose she told abc
i was not crazy it was a way for me to
deal in a sort of simulated but
controlled situation it was still awful
and the body doesn't understand when
it's in a fight
so this is a person who was not raped
had ptsd
from not
her rape but from witnessing another
person's response to a rape
and had a friend simulate rape in which
she was beaten
okay so this is the person that we are
talking about
does this sound like a mentally ordered
person to you a well-ordered person to
you
and this is not to rip on people who
have mental disorders there are people
in my family with mental disorders my
grandfather i've talked about it openly
was a manic depressive who was suicidal
from time to time okay so this is not to
mock the mentally disordered this is to
point out that when a society treats
mental disorders as perfectly healthy
behavior you incentivize mental
disorders and by the way you don't heal
anybody you don't make anybody better
in fact in many cases you make them
worse when you humor mental disorder
you are not making the mental disorder
better
my grandfather who was manic depressive
as i mentioned
he had the experience of believing that
the radio was talking to him telling him
to kill himself
and for years
my grandmother who just passed away
my grandmother
would lie in bed and tie her foot to his
because she knew that if he got up in
the middle of the night he might try to
kill himself with a razor okay that is
what mental disorders are
to pretend that the radio actually was
talking to him and we just needed to
humor that would have been cruelty it
wasn't until he got on lithium decades
later that he actually began to live a
normal life
a treating people who are mentally
disordered as though that is a form of
mental order and that it's only society
that has done something wrong is cruel
and nasty
and then to dictate to the rest of the
world that the rest of the world is
supposed to mirror this perspective is
insane and it promotes insanity
okay and this brings us to the new york
magazine cover piece my penis myself i
didn't need a penis to be a man but i
needed one to be me
well actually it turns out you're not a
man it turns out you're a biological
woman with
as evidenced by your own coverage of the
issues
some problems
and i feel honest to god i feel terrible
for this person but to pretend that this
person is just a mentally healthy man is
ridiculous on every possible level that
is possible for it it makes a mockery of
the word ridiculous to suggest this is
ridiculous
he'll get some more of this in just one
and by by the way demanding that all of
us acquiesce and approve and cheer and
putting it on the cover of magazines
hey this is 1984 doublethink that is
what this is
we'll get some more of this in just one
moment first
i am thrilled to announce an incredible
app everyone who buys gas needs to know
about get upside my listeners are making
up to 25 cents for every gallon of gas
every time they fill up just download
that free get upside app in the app
store or google play right now use promo
code shapiro get a bonus 25 cents per
gallon on your first fill up that's up
to 50 cents cash back don't pay full
price of the pump anymore get cash back
using get upside just download the app
for free use promo code shapiro get up
to 50 cents per gallon cashback on your
very first tank of gas some people who
drive are making as much as two to three
hundred dollars a month in cash back if
i have a lot of miles you're gonna save
a lot of money there's no catch the cash
back gets added directly to your account
you can cash out any time to your bank
account paypal or an egift card for
amazon and other brands just download
that free get upside app use promo code
shapiro to get up to 50 cents per gallon
cashback on your first tank that is code
shapiro again the gas prices right now
are super inflated so if you can save
money why exactly would you not go to
the app store download that free get
upside app use code shapiro and you
could be getting up to 50 cents per
gallon cashback on your first tank of
gas and then up to 25 cents per gallon
every gallon after that get the get
upside app today okay so this brings us
to the actual cover story from new york
magazine
okay
on the day i heard that my penis would
be huge i sobbed
in the car outside the doctor's office
afterward i bent my torso in half and
bald my face against the dashboard my
boyfriend petting my back to console me
but confused isn't it good news that
they can do it like at all and obviously
yes it was growing up without one i
thought or maybe convinced myself that
mine would grow in later to the extent
that when i see a woman in thai pants i
still often instinctively think where is
her penis
but my period at 12 aptly agonizingly
bled to death that increasingly
implausible dream of reconciling with
life with god that he wouldn't make me
like this and leave me like this forever
so the news 28 years later that the
agony was going to be over abundantly
over was a bit much to take in
i fixated on the information that a pert
little average flaccid package was not
an option for me
when i asked the surgeon how big my
impending penis was going to be he could
only guess pointing to the reusable
water bottle in my hand a metal cylinder
nine inches in circumference smaller
than that
i was so different from everybody else i
had always been so different
phalloplasty in general it was clear it
was hard for people to accept
well i will love you no matter what
sweetie a cis female best friend of mine
said when i told her i was transitioning
years before as long as you don't get a
dick one flatly demanded don't get a
dick it was another transmasculine
person i used to know said disgusting
insane to want or to have a surgeon make
a sensate phallus out of your arm or leg
or somewhere and frankenstitch it to
your body to go so far out of your way
to opt into a tool perhaps the tool of
so much suffering i love that there are
people who are so left-wing that the
presence
of
a penis is
itself
somehow an act of violence okay most
trans masculine people don't get one the
seminole prince trans mask magazine was
named after not getting one original
plumbing
i saw trans masculine support groups
shut down and go silent more than once
when someone brought up the procedure
later when i was that someone i was
twice invited to leave with other people
who might want to talk about that
whatever magical spectrum of unicorn
gender expression was otherwise being
embraced it ended firmly before needing
a socially culturally politically
historically personally emotionally
medically complicated dick but i did and
i couldn't outrun it any longer
literally the day i gave in and admitted
that for me it was penis or death came
after a last-ditch bout of denial in
which i drove 1400 miles in three days
only to have acknowledged devastated at
my destination that i couldn't avoid it
anymore
so this person had to call six surgeons
offices
and pcp's office 19 times for referrals
the insurance company 17 times for
necessary authorization
and um
these folks get together people who have
had the surgery and uh discussed the
feeling of having a surgically created
penis
and what size testicle implants to get
this person says
quote there's a scene in disney's
original dumbo when the child's elephant
mom cradles him in her trunk and sings
to him exuding love quietly but wholly
as a kid feeling utterly unheld by this
world i hated it as a grown man in a
hospital bed chest loosely draped with a
gown in a low-lit december room i looked
down in the direction of a penis i'd
assumed would be covered in bandages but
then there it was laid out in an angle
toward my left thigh propped on a green
cloth an eye odd and heartful and
weeping sang that song to it baby mine i
don't know the words
well i've been sleeping two micro
surgeons a recruit reconstructive
urologist a surgical fellow and a
surgical resident had among other things
cut a seven seven by six inch rectangle
out of my right anterior lateral thigh
they'd taken all the skin and fat plus
one big nerve and some veins attached to
the muscle and connected the skin itself
in the shape of a phallus then they
slipped the whole thing under two of my
thigh muscles pulled up out of the way
with a steel retractor dragged the
phallus across my groin under the skin
and pulled it back out into the world
through a hole cut in the skin over my
pubic bone it connected the new penis's
nerve to one of the nerve bundles in my
native penis which some people call a
clitoris
and it's not a native penis that's
called a clitoris which they'd cut free
of its ligaments then skinned then
tunneled up under the skin and out to
the landing side of the new penis the
base of which they joined the base of my
pelvis putting me all back together with
sutures some finer than a human hair
that penis dr balbach safa one of the
micro surgeons said when he came by to
see me after to see us looks perfect
he was mostly talking about the blood
flow he did not mean that with its fresh
stitches and a round bloody hole at the
top where the skin would eventually
close together it would look like any
other penis at the spa but also it was a
lovely shape
okay so are we supposed to believe that
this makes you a man
is that the idea that this makes you so
according to this person this didn't
make them a man the feeling made them a
man but they needed the penis in order
to feel complete
and then this needed to be put on the
cover of new york magazine to promote
the idea that this is
a reflection of biological reality that
this person is a man now
understand this article is not about
gabriel mack and this person's
experiences in life this article is
about you
because the goal is to make you believe
make you believe that two and two are
five
that is the goal and if you refuse to
believe two and two or five this makes
you a bigot this makes you a bad person
this means you'll be socially ostracized
this means that common sense must go by
the wayside the demand is not
for quote unquote tolerance the demand
is for acceptance and celebration
and belief more than anything else
belief
radical subjectivism is not the way any
functional society can work
because radical subjectivism eventually
this is the point in 1984 radical
subjectivism eventually will be
subjugated in favor of a top-down
version of reality that somebody wants
to impose and that top-down version of
reality that somebody wants to impose
particularly the folks in the media is a
version of reality
that is absolutely contrary to
actual biological
physical reality but allows for the
possibility of innate malleability of
humanity in any direction that they
choose
that's the goal
again i'm
gabriel matt can do whatever gabriel
mack wants to do in a free country
although again i think surgeons who
perform these sorts of surgeries are
doing nobody any great service i think
that the the notion that that obvious
mental disorders are going to be solved
by by brutal surgeries that require
years of healing in many cases
that this is not
in that
20 years from now people are going to
look back at this in the same way that
people look at at
curing seizures by putting an ice ice
pick in your eye like this
by doing lobotomies
like this is
but put that aside
what this is really about more than
anything else is getting you
again to believe tune to r5 that's what
this is about
alrighty in just one second we'll get to
the latest on oh micron where everybody
has spiraled into panic again the data
on omicron suggests this thing is not
particularly deadly we'll get to that in
just one moment first
it is a great time of year to get
somebody the most meaningful gift so
what is the most meaningful gift legacy
box okay so as i mentioned a little bit
earlier on in the show my grandmother
who was 91 passed away over the course
of the last week well one thing that was
amazing that i'd done for my parents and
that really
has helped them in this time is i used
legacy box about a year ago and we
preserved all the old family photos so
we took all the old family photos that
were they were in boxes in the garage
and we shipped them off to legacy box
and now they are digitally preserved
forever which is an amazing amazing
thing it means they can pass those
photos on to me and to my kids
legacy box makes that happen for you
right you got a bunch of old films out
in the garage you got a bunch of old
film reels or vhs tapes you can't use
those anymore so get those digitally
transferred over and now they are
accessible and make a great gift to
family
again legacy box is a very it's one of
those meaningful things i've ever done
for my parents you can future proof your
family's legacy relax knowing your
irreplaceable moments can be easily
viewed shared and passed on for future
generations their exclusive barcoded
online tracking system provides up to 12
emailed updates along the way prices are
under 40 bucks make this holiday season
special give the gift of memories with
christmas just around the corner there's
still time to buy the best christmas
gift ever visit legacybox.com shapiro
take advantage of an exclusive discount
for listeners legacy boxes are still in
stock ready to ship visit legacybox.com
shapiro for an exclusive offer that's
legacybox.com
shapiro already meanwhile
omicron panic continues to wash across
the land like a vast ugly tidal wave
yesterday joe biden laid out his plan
for omicron suffice it to say joe
biden's plan for omicron is going to be
completely ineffective because guess
what's going to be effective against
omicron the answer you may have guessed
is nothing that is correct
it turns out the omicron stats from
south africa are demonstrating that
omicron is not
supremely dangerous it is not as
dangerous as delta it's not as dangerous
as the original variant south africa is
about 25 to 30 vax
but omicron which is spiked in south
africa and now is coming down the other
side in south africa did not kill
massive numbers of people in fact it
killed so few people in south africa
that anthony fauci has been forced to
actually acknowledge the reality which
is that natural immunity might be a
thing because so many people in south
africa had already had covet and when
they got omicron it didn't matter very
much
it's amazing to see anthony fauci
suddenly acknowledge that natural
immunity ought to be taken into account
here he was discussing south africa
it is likely
that the reason that it is less severe
is that in south africa what you have is
a very large proportion of the
population has already been infected and
recovered and a relatively smaller
proportion have been vaccinated so it is
likely
that the protection against infection is
not very good because it'll get into the
nasopharynx and infect you the reason
they may have a less severe is that the
underlying cross protection that you
have
from an experience of a virus of a
different variant
might actually be protecting you from
severe disease which predominantly
involves the lungs okay so um i'm
noticing here that suddenly he believes
in natural immunity welcome to the club
which has been around as a martin
coldwell former professor at harvard
medical school says that the club of
people who have understood natural
immunity is a thing has existed for oh
approximately 1700 years something like
that
hey i'm glad that anthony fauci has
finally joined the club that doesn't
mean by the way he's not going to press
for vax mandates even for people who
already have natural immunities so
president biden decided to give a speech
yesterday the speech is not directed at
actually solving the problem
the speech is directed at pretending to
solve the problem because again when it
comes to this cult the high priesthood
must maintain that if only you would
obey them the problems would be solved
the problems won't be solved okay you're
not solving omicron it is 70 times as
transmissible as delta delta was twice
as transmissible as the original variant
that means that omicron is 140 times as
transmissible as the original variant in
other words we're all getting omicron in
the same way we all get a cold and
here's the good news by these statistics
available from south africa and from the
uk by the way you're not going to die
from it in fact you are probably going
to get mildly ill from it if you're
vaccinated you're almost certainly going
to get only mildly ill from it if you're
unvaccinated theoretically you could get
more sick we don't know how much more
sick
not as sick as you would have been if
you got delta
so president biden has now outlined his
strategy apparently the strategy
includes doubling down on vax campaigns
and propping up hospitals as they
confront a large influx of patients
federal officials will direct resources
including army doctors to support health
care systems and distribute rapid tests
to americans
uh president biden's speech was mostly
directed at trying to scare the living
hell out of you but here is the thing
omicron should be the time when you're
not so scared
okay i i'm noticing all around me
institutions that are shutting their
schools that are shutting down for
example in the face of omicron kids are
not dying even of delta they are
certainly not dying of omicron
we should not be testing the
asymptomatic
we should not be pursuing a lockdown
strat that's what this ends with by the
way if you test the asymptomatic you're
locking down society it's that simple
omicron is too transmissible too many
people have it
so if the idea is that if you're
diagnosed with omicron and you're
asymptomatic you're now supposed to stay
home for 10 days and you combine that
with everyone should get tested half of
society will be staying home
you will shut down the entire economy of
the united states
okay but everything they do is not
geared towards success it's geared
toward leaving the impression that they
can control this thing
so in reality here's the actual solution
to omicron you ready for this are you
ready for this you should get vast if
you're vulnerable or if you're older you
should have done that the entire
pandemic i've been very clear about this
and then if you get omicron
that's all you will get omicron we all
get omicron we will virtually all
survive and we'll move on with our lives
done that's the plan i know it sounds
really crazy and really difficult to say
that some people are going to get mildly
ill and then that's going to be the end
of it but that's kind of what the stats
show
at this point
david joe biden so joe biden is in a
tough spot he's made a catch-22 for
himself on the one hand if he shuts down
the economy his presidency continues to
crater on the other hand he has
suggested that he is going to shut down
the virus i mean he literally tweeted
out he would shut down the virus which
no human being is capable of doing
so that means that he's going to try to
split the baby he says we should be
concerned about omicron but not panicked
uh i have an idea i'm vast i'm not
concerned or panicked about omicron and
as far as my kids go i'm not concerned
or panicked about my kids getting
omicron because nobody who knows any of
the data is concerned about kids getting
omicron
my parents are triple vaccine i'm not
concerned about them getting omagron
my wife is triple vaxxed because she's a
doctor i'm not worried about her getting
omicron
so um how about i'm not concerned or
panicked
uh here's joe biden anyway
we should all be concerned about omicron
but not panicked
if you're fully vaccinated and
especially if you got your booster shot
you are highly protected
and if you're unvaccinated
you're at a higher risk getting severely
ill from covert 19 getting hospitalized
and even dying
so the best thing to do is get fully
vaccinated and get your booster shot
okay well
as far as the booster shots go what the
data tend to show is that if you are
elderly or immunocompromised you should
get a booster shot because what the
boosters basically do is they increase
the number of antibodies in your system
antibodies prevent the infection so you
can get a temporary boost and that will
prevent the infection for a certain
period of time if you have a slower
immune system which is what it means to
be older or be immunocompromised this
means that preventing the disease is
probably
a good bet right it's worthwhile if
you're 30 your t cell b cell memory is
going to kick in and you're going to be
able to fight this off so you will get
infected and then you'll have a mild
cold and your nose will run and then
you'll be done
okay so that is that is why boosters are
are in opposite for everyone in fact
there are many scientists including the
who who suggest that boosters for 30
year olds should be foregone in favor of
getting first doses to people who are in
africa who have not been vaccinated at
all for example
okay then joe biden again he's trying to
split the baby because he's stuck he has
made a promise he cannot fulfill
he was going to shut down the virus but
he can't shut down the virus so on the
one hand we're not going back to march
2020 because if we go back to march 2020
he's toast his party's toast he knows it
so here he says we're not going back to
march 2020 conditions
but
somebody needs to ask him why we're not
going back to march 2020 conditions
considering that omicron is going to
spread way faster than the original
variant and you're telling people to be
concerned
another question that folks are asking
is are we going back to march 2020 not
just last march 2021
but march 2020 when the pandemic first
hit
and that's what i keep getting asked the
answer is absolutely no
no
here are three big differences between
then and now
one
number one the first one
more than 200 million americans have
been fully vaccinated
in march
of 2020
no one was fully vaccinated okay so he's
saying that the vaccinations are what is
going to prevent us from going march
2020 but you and your administration are
saying that people who get it are still
going to have to quarantine for up to 10
days
which means effectively speaking that if
you have mass testing combined with that
particular rule
and lack of symptoms
you will go back to march 2020 it won't
be a formal lockdown it won't be shut
your business's doors it will be
businesses cannot operate without their
employees or their customers
so you will back door march 2020 into
actual policy
okay so then joe biden says you can
celebrate christmas if you and those who
celebrate with you are vaccinated now
here's what makes no sense about this if
you're vaccinated you should be able to
celebrate with the unvaccinated
that's the reality the vaccines work at
preventing hospitalization and death and
you can be infected by somebody else
who's vaccinated
half the people i know at this point
probably have omicron and have infected
each other and they're vaccinated so
nobody cares
hey but here is joe biden saying a
nonsensical thing
and i know some americans are wondering
if you can safely celebrate the holidays
with your family and friends
the answer is yes you can
if you and those you celebrate with are
vaccinated particularly if you've gotten
your booster shot
if you are vaccinated and follow the
precautions that we all know well
you should feel comfortable celebrating
christmas and the holidays as you
planned it
you know you've done the right thing you
can enjoy the holiday season
okay well here's the thing if you're
unvaccinated you can also enjoy the
holiday season you're just at higher
risk than the vaccinated
okay and then he gets to th this is
kind of an amazing statement from joe
biden so he says we're vaccinating you
to save your life and we're not
vaccinating you because we want to
control your life we're vaccinating you
to save your life
well
if this standard were held by the
government the government would control
your life
and because it turns out that the number
one cause of death in the united states
is heart disease heart disease is highly
linked to obesity do you really want the
government deciding what you can eat on
a daily basis realistically speaking the
principle of which he is speaking this
broad principle that the government can
do anything it wants in order to save
your life
is uh
as we say overbroad
okay here's joe biden saying we're
vaccinating you to save your life not
control your life
i know vaccination requirements are
unpopular
for many
i'm not even popular for those who are
anxious to get them
my administration has put them in place
not to control your life but to save
your life
in the lives of others
okay so saving the lives of others is
not really the issue in the sense that
again vaccinated people can transmit the
disease
it is true that if you could force if
you were a benevolent dictator and you
could force everybody to get vaccine
fewer people would die the problem is we
still have in this country a baseline
notion that you should be able to make
decisions about your own health that
affect
you
okay that that is just that that is a
baseline level of liberty
and once the government gets to decide
that they can do whatever they want in
order to quote unquote save your life
that means there are no limits they end
up in michael bloomberg land no soda no
meat no eggs
and we all we all eat like joe biden
wants us to eat if there's no limiting
principle here there's no end to the
control which of course is kind of the
idea there is no end to the control by
the way there's a certain irony here
that irony is that joe biden's press
secretary jensachi was asked yesterday
about whether joe biden had coveted
and her answer was uh less than edifying
how is the president feeling given close
contact is he systematic is he doing
okay i know he's getting touched
tomorrow but he'll give us an update uh
he's asymptomatic i spent several hours
with him uh this morning uh and he is
feeling great and you'll see him at the
speech shortly no question uh that was
not the question the question was has
the president tested recently and jen
saki's answer was he's asymptomatic
okay so that's actually a good answer if
you hold by my logic that is a terrible
answer if you hold by joe biden's logic
by my logic if you're asymptomatic i
don't care whether you have coveted
i really don't
because asymptomatic people have all
sorts of stuff
we have never in the history of humanity
tested people for asymptomatic things
with the intent of shutting down their
lives
the notion of testing the asymptomatic
is a bizarre one
so by my lights if joseph joe biden is
asymptomatic he doesn't need to test but
we've been told that joe biden tests
every day and we're told that earlier
this month so if he tests every day and
gensake saying he's asymptomatic that
means that there's a good shot that he
actually has kovid and is asymptomatic
and yet he's out there doing what he
wants to do i'm not sure what else i'm
supposed to take away from gensake
answering the question as to his covet
positive status by saying he is
asymptomatic
you don't get to use gensake logic here
you have to use my logic to come to that
particular conclusion okay what all this
is resulting in is is a vastly
discombobulated policy and you can see
it on the left i mean they're just
running around waving their hands around
in the air like the crazy inflatable men
at the used car lot
it's just a bunch of conflicting
proposals that make no sense in tandem
with one another we'll get to that in
just one second first
let's say that you are a dinosaur living
in prehistoric times and the weather has
started to turn the volcanoes have
started to erupt and all you want to do
is get your little dinosaur child to
safety we'll call him littlefoot but
something goes dramatically wrong well
as you lay your head down for the last
time you might think to yourself man at
the very least i should have gotten
littlefoot some treestar life insurance
you should have used policy genius head
on over to policygenius.com shapiro
right now answer a few questions about
yourself in minutes you can work out how
much life insurance coverage you need
compare personalized quotes to find your
best price you could save 50 or more on
life insurance by comparing quotes with
policy genius their licensed experts
will help you understand your options
and apply for a policy the policy genius
team works for you not the insurance
company you can trust them to offer
unbiased help and advocate for you at
every step until you are covered policy
genius does not add on extra fees or
sell your information to third parties
head on over to policygenius.com shapiro
get your free life insurance quotes see
how much you could save that's
policygenius.com
shapiropolicygenius.com shapiro go check
it out right now okay we're gonna get to
the actual policy preferences of this
administration in just one second first
a couple of big announcements first last
night the daily wear premiered a very
special episode of candace candace owns
traveled to mar-a-lago for a
face-to-face interview with former
president donald trump for an in-depth
conversation with one of the most
censored men on planet earth here is
candace on the interview today i'm going
to sit down with him and i'm going to
give him a fair but a tough interview
with critiques that have come from his
own side
i voted for president trump make no
mistake but there are tons of questions
that need answering and i hope that i'm
able to deliver that to you all today
welcome to candace
the interview is streaming exclusively
two members at dailywire.com head on
over to dailywire.com
subscribe to join today and start
watching if you dig candace head on over
to the yesweekhandus.com store pick up
some awesome candace merch also we have
a brand new show it's called the search
i love this show basically you get to be
a fly on the wall for conversations i
have with some of my smartest friends we
just go to a coffee shop and we talk and
we talk about family and we talk about
life we talk about meaning the first
episode with jordan peterson available
right now at dailywire.com is stellar
it's really it's a different look it's a
different feel because it's not formal
it's really informal and that's kind of
the best conversations you ever have or
with a friend over coffee well now you
get to watch me have coffee with my
friends
and it's it's terrific go check out the
search right now at dailywire.com also
the bind administration continues to use
the pandemics to strip americans of our
freedoms the daily wire is fighting back
we are closing in on our goal of one
million signatures on our do not comply
petition we need your help to take us
over the finish line by christmas is the
goal by new year's if we don't make that
it's necessary the sixth circuit this
week lifted the stay on the vax mandate
we are now appealing directly to the
supreme court joe biden's wins her plan
will involve more vast mandates if you
believe by the way it's going to stop at
companies with over 100 employees wrong
you are the cdc is going to extend this
to everyone reaching a million
signatures will provide a major boost
for our legal challenge please sign the
petition at dailywire.com do not comply
share our position with all of your
friends and family you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
so what exactly are the proposals that
emerge from this very confused
discombobulated administration they've
created a catch-22 for themselves yes
we'll stop kovid also we can't stop
kovat this creates a lot of bizarre
proposals so the great and powerful
anthony falci he says that um
if you're unvaxed you should stay away
from the facts and vice versa here's dr
anthony fauci explaining
if someone in your family isn't
vaccinated should you ask them not to
show up
uh yes i would do that i mean i think
we're dealing with a serious enough
situation right now that if there's an
unvaccinated person i would say i'm very
sorry but not this time maybe another
time when this is all over
um okay that's ridiculous if you're vast
you shouldn't be afraid of the unfacts
you should be done
and meanwhile the new york times is
saying maybe schools are going to have
to close no schools don't have to close
the kids are not vulnerable you idiots
and yet dana goldstein writes for the
new york times the dread was familiar as
news spread of the latest coveted surge
fueled by the omicron variant parents
face to return to the drudgery of school
through a screen child care crises and
restless young bodies penned inside for
the winter in manhattan olivia strong
received an email from her son's public
middle school on monday informing her
that his cohort of 8th graders would
transition to remote learning because of
multiple positive virus cases i fully
expected it she said signing deeply
her hope she added was that a short
break to reset would allow schools to
reopen more safely in the new
year
i mean i'm sorry this is insane this is
insane kids are not dying of this virus
they've not been dying of this virus the
entire time
and yet they continue now that now
they're talking about school shutdowns
really like all over the country there
are people who are talking about school
shutdowns because of the coveted
paranoid
members of the the coveted cult have
decided that they are going to ensure
that kids
are not allowed to go to school which by
the way raises anxiety and depression
among kids we saw a vast amount of that
over the course of the last year and a
half it means they fall behind now that
the masking of kids is having some
pretty dire effects on on how kids
operate in the real world the data are
in and masking has serious downsides
which is not shocking it turns out when
you take small kids and you don't expose
them to human faces they're not that
good at reading emotions it it actually
screws with their iq it is not good
and yet this administration is at the
same time joe biden is saying it's not
march 2020. meanwhile the administration
is like well it might be march 2020. so
here's education secretary miguel
cardona saying that school shutdowns in
the first place were not overdone
on what basis on what basis
absolutely not and i'm not only speaking
as an educator but as a parent uh not
only uh did we want to make sure we
protected our children and our staff
with information that we know now but we
didn't know then but i think it's really
important to remind folks that children
can carry it and they could spread it to
their grandparents they could spread it
to family members back at a time when we
didn't have vaccines you know we lost so
many lives um and i believe that the
precautions that we took uh weren't
necessary okay europe didn't shut down
at schools and um
nope this is just wrong this is wrong i
mean the evidence that school shutdowns
were a good idea that evidence does not
exist the evidence is completely absent
in every possible way and by the way if
he thinks that it was bad in march 2020
and the problem is you could infect
grandma well guess what omicron is way
more infectious
so why wouldn't they push for school
shutdowns meanwhile rochelle willenski
was questioned about masking and
vaccinating kids because again kids are
not dying of the virus and also there
are there's no evidence that masking
kids is useful at all
and so she's just not going to answer
the question she's just going to
maintain that you have to do all of
these things because this is what the
cult requires
will you follow the science and stop
relying on faulty studies
and end mass mandates for children in
schools
response um you know there have been
study after study not only in this
country but in other countries that have
demonstrated um that our layered
prevention strategies including
masculine schools are able to keep our
schools safely open it's none to keep
our schools open and the best way to do
that is to use those layered prevention
strategies um and that includes not only
vaccinating our children but and our
adults but also to continue to mask
certainly in the context of this hype
very transmissible um omicron variant
she has not one shred of evidence okay
the question here was okay richarlinesky
is over and over and over cited a bad
study the atlantic completely debunked
the study there was a study that she
kept citing saying that p that school
children were three times more likely to
get coveted if there was no mass mandate
that study is complete garbage it does
not work
it does not use comparable control
groups it is just it's a nonsense study
the atlantic okay not a right wing
organization the atlantic completely
ripped that study apart she's asked
about it and her response is i'm just
not even going to cite data i'm just
going to tell you what you ought to do
i mean this is this is craziness it's
craziness so they say they don't want to
shut down society they say that the
vaccinated should be able to lead normal
lives then they're like also you should
never associate with an unvaxxed person
again also your kids must be vacs also
you should get boosters also you should
continue to wear a mask also we should
test the asymptomatic joe biden wants
500 million tests for people to test and
people are lining up around the block in
major cities around the united states
convinced by the media they must test
for omicron if they've got a sniffle
this is craziness folks it's nuts
andy slavitt former white house senior
advisor on covet he's now saying that we
need to push for more boosters and
require booster shots we need to require
booster shots not for the most
vulnerable but for everyone
we need to require boosters weird israel
has had third shots of boosters and
guess what they still have an omicron
outbreak in fact that omicron outbreak
is so severe they're now requiring
fourth shots in israel
you should get your punch card if you
finally get to 12 then you get a free
donut it's exciting stuff happening here
in in chicago lori lightfoot the
complete
herd of a mayor
she she
was suggesting quote to put it simply if
you have been living vaccine free your
time is up if you wish to live life as
with the ease to do the right things you
love you must be vast this health order
may pose an inconvenience to the
unvaccinated and in fact it is
inconvenient by design
she's deliberately making your life
worse if you are unvaxxed
and then she says she's going to call
for vax passports the vax passports are
completely useless they're useless
vaccinated people are passing this new
york city has had a vac passport for
months at this point
they have a massive outbreak in new york
city
this is not designed to elicit the
actual
result that they supposedly want which
means that what is it actually designed
to do maximize power and get you to
signal that you've got skin in the game
and that you're going to side with the
cult
also exempt are any individuals entering
an establishment for less than 10
minutes for the purpose of merely
ordering food or drink
so if you're going in that coffee shop
to pick up and go
you don't need to show proof but if
you're going to linger you're going to
eat that muffin you're going to sit down
with your laptop you got to show proof
of vaccination by the way if you go into
a a coffee shop and you stand in line
for 10 minutes unvaccinated that is
plenty of time to infect everybody
around you so obviously this is not
designed to elicit a response it's
designed to just pressure people
that pressure is not going to be
successful
then they say and if you're not massed
and somebody gets
that gets omicron then you have to test
everybody why
why
okay but if they're mass you don't have
to test everybody so in order to shore
up the lie you can't get infected by
somebody with a cloth mask who's seven
years old
in order to shore up that lie you have
to not test everybody but if they're
unmasked then you have to test everybody
why it's almost as though you're rigging
the system in order to come up with
positive tests when there are no masks
it's almost as though you've created a
system to redouble
your data at the expense of actual data
it's incredible do you see the trick
they're flying the trick is we will only
look at the tests
among the unmasked
but we will never look at the test among
the mast
because because we know that masks work
already you don't you haven't provided
any data on this whatsoever here's the
actual solution unmask the kids leave
them the hell alone don't test the
asymptomatic if you're symptomatic go
home
done just like the flu just like every
other disease in the history of
humankind
you know where the sense this ends for
for the left never it ends with model
citizens okay so this was the model
citizen on twitter yesterday
i just have to show you this model
citizen is a person named dana scott
dana not scully at telefeminism
do you have a picture of this human
there should be a picture of this human
attached to the swede yes there it is
all right so
if you can't see this this is why you
should subscribe and watch the video
this person describes flying quote i'm
flying today
but i'm not effing around with omicron
check pfizer times three check negative
rapid test check natural immunity check
n95 sealed to my face with surgical tape
check secondary mask for displaying
opinions check face shield check vinyl
gloves check touch screen gloves check
leap ton of xanax
so
um
this is the model citizen
this
this person should win the medal of
honor this person is the
most important person in america this
person understands omicron this person
understands how you're supposed to
protect yourself just to repeat you're
supposed to triple that
you're supposed to test negative
you've already had covid which means you
have natural immunity but you triple
vaccine anyway
then you're not only supposed to wear an
n95 you're supposed to seal the n95 to
your face using surgical tape
but that's not enough the real key i
think the real key in this description
is the secondary mask for displaying
your opinions that's the key because if
you wear a mask
that that
has a that says vote on it which is what
this mask says then omicron definitely
will leave you alone i mean we learned
this during blm last year right i mean
during blm we learned that you could go
ahead and twerk for george floyd without
a mask
and
you would never be hit by the variant
ever you would never be hit by by the
original variant or by by anything in
fact you're immune from death so long as
you're working for george floyd this is
what we learned from our scientific
community last year so she's right you
know in fact she's so right she could
dismiss all the rest of the things she
wouldn't need as long as she had a cloth
face mask that said vote on it she'd be
done she'd be good to
go she also has a face shield vinyl
gloves touch screen gloves and bleep ton
of xanax
yeah the xanax i think is probably the
key ingredient here i think that's most
likely the key ingredient we have
decided to panic ourselves over a
variant that is essentially the common
cold for the vast majority of people who
get it
we have decided to destroy the lives of
our children on the shoals of coveted
panic because our government actors lied
to us about what they could do and what
they couldn't do
that is what they've done
it is insane but i guess they feel
better about themselves ruining lives
by the way the covet hospitalizations in
south africa just going to point this
out
they're falling
they're falling already
they lasted for five seconds and then
they fell
and to pretend that the data is is not
in is ridiculous the data are in
it is eric topel okay who is not a wild
right-winger
he tweeted out a study yesterday that
the south african pre-print data says 70
reduction in illness severity compared
with delta and prior variants 70
my guess is probably higher than that
but they
they're going to continue they must they
must continue because again it's about
the faith they're gonna make a bunch of
moves that restrict your life because
the more you restrict your life the more
virtuous you are
the more restricted you are the more
because this is a religious practice at
this point that's all this is it is a
religious practice and so you must
listen to the daughtering old fool in
the white house telling you a bunch of
contradictory things you must listen to
her shelensky when she says you need to
ask your kids you must listen to andy
slavin when he says you have to boost
the unborn
and you have to do all of these things
despite the fact that there are
countervailing arguments
and by the way on boosters marty mccarry
are friends of the show
from johns hopkins
he says it's actually dangerous to push
boosters for teens
he says booster mandates for healthy
young people which some colleges are
imposing will cause medical harm for the
sake of transient reductions in mild and
asymptomatic infections in a study of
438 000 males 16 to 24 56 developed
myocarditis after their second physio
dose most cases were mild but in the
broader group of 136 people who
developed myocarditis seven had a
complicated course one 22 year old died
modernist vaccine carries an even higher
rate of heart complications which is why
some european countries have restricted
it for people under 30. but in the
united states the fda and cdc are
indiscriminately pushing boosters for
all young people
again all of this is being done
in the absence of real data suggesting
that 18 year olds need a booster in the
first place
but once again i will just repeat this
until i'm blue in the face the goal is
not to stop omicron because you can't
the goal
is not even to prevent death from
omicron because whatever death is going
to happen is going to happen the goal is
to maintain the lie that they are in
control and the only reason we have
failed to stop this is because of your
lack of fealty
they are very disappointed in your lack
of faith alrighty we will be back here
today with an additional hour of content
in the meantime please head on over to
dailywire.com do not comply
we are very close to 1 million
signatures we need your help because of
course we've appealed the biden vax
mandate to the supreme court please help
us get to a million signatures
dailywear.com do not comply in the
meantime go check out the michael
knowles show in today's show attorney
general garland says criminals released
from prison due to covet won't be sent
back and collected you can hear more
details about that story over on
michael's show that's available right
now i'm ben shapiro this is the ben
shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover production manager pavo
widowsky associate producer bradford
carrington host producer justin barber
the show is edited by adam sciovitz
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola cristina production
assistant jessica kranz the ben shapiro
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021
cnn's medical analyst tells the public
not to wear cloth masks democrat senator
joe manchin pushes back on the white
house and attorney general merrick
garland releases thousands of criminals
check it out on the michael knowles show
[Music]